vuol dire vista roba prima di cominciare
perché far scattare la prime 3 donne e
bore un gioco che si comprano è che non
è ancora uscito ufficialmente ma si
compra costa tipo 30 e 29 99 quindi
costa 30 euro
tu metti la tua email loro lo mandano
via mail spendi sti 30 euro mamma è una
cosa che io avevo già fatto perché ci ho
già fatto degli episodi ogni volta che
c'è un aggiornamento te lo danno poi
grati se lo paghi una volta sola sono io
quella mail che mi avevano mandato per
le versioni precedenti non la trovo più
cercata per un'ora e non la trovavo
allora per registrarlo dovuto
ricomprarlo di nuovo perché non trovavo
più quello di prima
appena mi è arrivata la mail con il
codice che questa qua ho ritrovato
subito ma amato subito proprio
istantaneamente la mail vecchia quindi
adesso ciò questo che link nuovo e
questo è il link vecchio che la stessa
cosa quindi ho buttato 30 euro quindi a
fifino spesso 30 euro più altri 30 euro
quindi 60 euro per un gioco che si
chiama è la nei board l'unica persona
molto riuscito a pagare 60 euro un gioco
che ne vale forse forse dieci forze e da
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono bravi j e toni siano tornati sul
livello neighbor che per altri 30 euro
ci deve essere non solo un gioco della
madonna che vuole venire il creatore del
gioco a pulirmi casa per 30 euro
busquets che
e c'è di tutto di nuovo cos'è sta roba
hanno aggiunto hanno aggiunto un filmato
iniziale che privata stai calmo era un
complimento il mio stai calmo ragazzi
quanto inquietante stai trova cos'è sta
roba hanno fatto è arrivata una lettera
di hogwarts
questa non è un quarto però magari con
un pò diversa vabbè ragazzi c'era
style.it nostrana bella il fatto che
devo traslocare ogni cristo di volta
elettro casa mia
che bella che è la mia casa perché chi
ci abitava dentro un puffo
ma cos'è sta roba ma nache a gas del
jazzista al cesso ma dentro miglia bella
bella spaziosa staccata fantastico
comunque ragazzi secondo me lo zio ha
manie di grandezza con ace stavolta si è
superato legge ma madonna ma cos'è sta
roba
l'altro c'è una piattaforma non saprà la
rai non ho capito ragazzi se lo scopo
del gioco a raggiungere chisti quindi sa
quale punto della casa però scopriremo
visto che c'è questa questa roba nuova
innanzi tutto qua c'è una bomba hai una
mano e lamela
va bene qua c'è una chiave la chiave di
casa mia questa sta la chiave di questa
chiave è parca vacca schifosa
la frase o una chiave non ho paura di
usarla ma è michael jackson
fantastico zioni segno da bravo lì che
fai la pausa merenda mentre fai la pausa
merenda attiva se io tipo tentò di
entrare di soppiatto in casa tua o tinca
70 non vivete
ecco magari ma magari la prossima volta
ci pensa 13 volte beh spero vivamente
che questa roba sia cola zero
niente laga lo zio mi vede allora a
questo punto direi di prova a fare un
altra roba da antonioni ecco infatti
dato mi becca comunque abbiamo capito ha
fatto avrei porta a porta a porta a
porta anzi approcciare sempre cazzo
vacca manca che sfiga
adesso è perso niente la madonna ma che
si guarda fuori stimato di checa 6
giovanni muciaccia conia stata 6 al volo
al volo al volo a loro però giorno c'è
la sola che non ti prendono ti prende
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
tu porca vacca saprò mai lo conte monio
incastrato nell'albero i mercoledì
mentre devo fare una roba non son
riuscito pazienza ci proviamo adesso e
non c'è perché sicuramente poco davanti
casa puoi andare a far qualcosa dentro
casa gamer che cazzo vuoi è casa mia
questa che faccio vuole a casa mia
questa fratello rientra in casa tua mi
fai un favore poi fino fare cose che non
siano stare davanti alla porta per
cortesia
la cosa che volevo fare ovviamente era
quella di andare di nuovo sopra
le scale vi ricordate la capitana come
sto vedermi ma dove si ce l'ho fatta qua
non ci puoi arrivare zio quindi inutile
va bene così mentre gli innaffio la
famiglia a questo tizio qua dentro
in teoria ci dovrebbe essere la solita
chiave anche che c'era l'altra volta
eccola qua ragazza la ricordavo giornali
c'è anche una leva può prendere la il
magnete lunga la mano allunga ma dai che
ci arrivi che pigro secondo me raga
ma che cazzo sei spider man
porca vacca schifo era possibile cosa
mickey è successo alla linea fiato io
volevo innaffiare il giardino perché mi
sei simpatico mi cavolo far niente di
male cioè scusa secondo te perché l'erba
del vicino è sempre più verde perché la
innaffiano io l'altro dove è andato
ragazzi ma che senso stima di chimica
messi in casa
tutti hanno preso un infarto mica può
essere chiara no a il lucchetto rosso
devo trovare ho capito lancio un
lucchetto giallo allora devo prendere la
chiave blu ragazzi ha funzionato
non ci credo un anno e mezzo la focosa
ti lanci sono su un tetto c'è un tetto
l'altro io potrei scassare il soffitto
una bassa domanda che ci posso credere
perfetto ci ho messo una vita per fare
sta roba c'è una idea c'è un balcone c'è
un botto di roba raga non so dove
possiamo andare da soli diano fatemi
capire dove sono emozionato scusatemi ma
darà quel punto io dovrei spaccare
questa di finestra con a spacco non c'è
niente lancio la chiave pensa che non
dovevo lanciarla la chiave perché non
entra cosa può fare qua dove sono un po
sfocato stato ok perfetto era meglio era
meglio se lanciamo una sedia a questo
punto li mortacci mia ma [ __ ] la
permesso la società non c'era una chiave
dove non dovevo lanciarla cazzo ma era
un coso che si è sollevato a mi chiede
soldi al summit ha trasportato le due
minchia siamo raga non ha idea di dove
siamo pero trovato questo che dovrebbe
essere magnete quindi con il magnete
dovrei riuscire a prendere la chiave
questo perché magari quest'anno la
lanciamo è che dice se la teniamo tanto
so anche che cosa appare quindi perfetto
qua c'è una torcia ok siamo in sette
abbastanza bene ragazzi
apri le case ha scavato cos'è sta roba
sap ed io non volevo ho sbagliato colpa
mia è una sedia sopracitata di fargli
capire dove portano queste porte
ora prendi offrendo tua madre zio
noi dobbiamo capirci il suo picco questo
caso da chi non aveva un cazzo su tutte
le chiavi perfetto tranne una che l'ha
lanciata però vabbè pazienza allora gli
attuali con queste femmine se si apre
questa si apre pure questa dove cazzo mi
porta sta roba è una femmina tenendo
skier meglio non scoprire le cose no non
appetito tutte le chiavi del mondo in un
secondo le ho prese non so come l'aria
aprista [ __ ] porta già fi che ferma
un attimo che modo a fare il salto della
vita ole
ma che cazzo
ma che cazzo ci fa una metro dentro casa
era questo il segreto del vicino c'era
una m nascosta e funziona pure rana
verde fantastico ragazzi fermi sono
arrivato in una parte che non capisco
dove cazzo siamo io non ho ancora usato
neanche una chiara e siamo arrivati qua
ragazzi pensate voi che cosa c'è là su
perfetto
lapresse a porta vuota frac ci sono i
controlli della metro
lo so capaci non ho mai giocato a mente
un simulator schiaccia il pulsante rosso
tira valeva rosso o cristo dio mi sa che
questa roba dovevo fare mentre non sopra
la metro mentre sono sotto posso andarci
a piedi teoria ci posso andare anche a
piedi ragazzi che cosa sta diventando
questo gioco cosa vizia sto vedere la
madonna ma guest radicato la metro di
londra
ho aperto qualcosa non so cosa non è ok
nel dubbio è tornata indietro l'opera 9
feb punta capo madre porca la cala fatto
il giro li mortacci mia sicop ati
costoso vincino ma ce l'avete l'idea via
via via via di qui vieni qua o ferma
fermati un secondo vai vai parte alla
insomma ce l'ho fatta sono la metro e
sapete cosa vi dico io che sono bastardo
chiudo l'episodio qua ragazzo venuto qua
perché voglio vedere cosa succedeva nel
prossimo episodio perché basta troppe
emozioni una volta sola proprio ai vini
sia per cento ragazzi abbiano scoperto
cosa c'è dietro le cose del vicino però
il video vi sia perciò mi avviate per
sta roba lo scopro io gli voglio bene ma
vi mando un bacio enorme perché vi amo
in fondo premi siamo 100 ragazzi cose se
vissuto come mi piace anche lazio
iniziare già sentiti chiedere ci vediamo
al prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]